i mean
i mean hi mia poncetto approached 14
year old keon harold jr at a new york
city hotel last month accusing him
of stealing her phone his father jazz
musician
keon harrell recorded the encounter and
accused poncetto
of racial profiling
no i'm not letting him walk away with my
phone
now the video shows poncetto trying to
stop the teenager from leaving the hotel
lobby and then rushing toward them
hotel surveillance video shows the 22
year old woman
tackling keon jr now he never had the
phone it turned up several minutes later
at the hotel
new york city detectives went to
california yesterday to coordinate
poncero's arrest in connection with the
confrontation
she was contacted at a traffic stop in
ventura county near los angeles
officials say that police had to pull
her out of the car when she refused to
get out
mia help me understand what made you
think that keon had your phone
that's why i'm confused why did you
think he had it i was approaching
the the people that had been exiting the
hotel because in my mind
anybody exiting is probably the one that
might be the one that is trying to steal
my phone
i admit yes i could have approached the
situation differently or maybe not
yelled at him like that and made him
feel
you know maybe some sort of uh inferior
way maybe not tackle them
and infringe on his personal space
but i was the only one you tackled and
entitled everybody that was going out
making him feel as if i was like
hurting his feelings because that's not
my intention i i consider myself to be
super sweet i really never
ever meant for it to like hurt him or
his father either are you saying that
you were stopping
everybody in the lobby asking them about
your phone is that what you're saying
um not everyone just the just the people
that
in the meantime well while the hotel
manager was
just the negros let's just say it's fine
just the negros i couldn't imagine
losing my phone and thinking i have the
right to stop people who are leaving a
hotel that i happen to be staying in
based off of any criteria i'm going to
search you
she tackled them what you mean nobody
even shouldn't go i'm going to search
you
no no but even if you just wanted to
search me
who are you if you got something stolen
call the cops you don't get to stop
people i don't care if you lost a
million dollars
you don't get to infringe on people's
personal space
it's not a complicated process how would
you feel if you were alone in new york
and you know you're going to spend time
with your family during the holidays
and you lose the one thing that gets
stolen from you that has all the access
to the only way that you're able to get
back home
you don't have access to social media
you got a laptop or a computer or
someone else so you're just using this
oh it's the phone number
it's all in the phone this girl's making
excuses like listen there's no
this is what i'm saying if you [ __ ] up
just get up there i'm sorry i messed up
and i really had a huge lapse in
judgment
all this talking all this jibber jabber
that you're doing is is making you look
worse
oh but abba wait there's more
what do you think when you look at that
video you're standing there in your
leggings and your flip-flops
and it looks like you're just going nuts
for lack of a better word
no i'm not letting you walk away with my
phone i don't feel that
that is who i am as a person i don't
feel like this one mistake does define
me but
i do sincerely from the bottom of my
heart apologize that if i made
the sun feel as if i assaulted him or if
i hurt his feelings or
the father's feelings if he feels like
you assaulted him
you assaulted him it's not a feeling
you're not black-eyed peace you ran at
him
you yell at him you tackle them that's a
fact
beyond feelings but anyways video seems
to show that you physically attacked
this young boy
you do see that too right but end of the
day the dad did end up
like slamming me to the ground and uh
pulling my hair
and throwing me and dragging me across
the ground so
i i will say that yeah but but i think
you know the video we saw it looked like
you had just attacked his son
yeah the footage shows me attacking his
son
of attacking him how yelling at him yes
okay i apologize can we move on
boo boo if someone jumped on my son i'd
punch you in the face
what did you talk about this
may be one of the most blatant forms of
like zero accountability i've ever seen
this is this is wild the yeah so the
video shows you attacking your son
yeah but the video shows him grabbing by
the hair and then tossing me to the
ground after you attacked his son
but wait eva there's more i know you're
saying i don't need to i'm just want to
apologize
but i do think that there should be some
context to your actions that day
okay so basically i'm
i'm a 22 year old girl i am i i don't
i racism uh is
i said i how is one girl accusing
a guy about a phone
a crime where is the context in that
is the deeper what is the deeper what is
the deeper yeah it's not it's
that's not the problem you have to at
least understand your actions that day
you seem to have attacked this little
boy this young boy this
yes teenager you seem to have attacked
this teenager about the phone
and then it turned out he didn't even
have your phone
that's the thing i mean you're you're
saying look i'm 22 years old you're 22
years old but you are old enough to know
better
so i will say you're 22. i killed enough
the hotel did have my phone
but i would never think of talking to
them okay okay gail
enough enough the amount of entitlement
that you have to walk through
we did that we did i feel bad for her
man
she gotta walk through life with that
kind of lack of self-awareness man
that's her problem
she gotta live with that it's one thing
to
do what she did blah blah blah it's
another thing to seemingly not be aware
of how you're being perceived or how
you're coming across to others how rude
all that stuff
when you lack that skill i'm telling you
you will suffer
so much in life and that is going to be
her lived experience so
i feel bad for her in that regards but
beyond that that was some garbage stuff
you
violated another person's space and you
know you could say how much
you're female see they always love to do
that every time they get physically
doing all this stuff they're like
oh well i'm a girl so yeah i see you
trying to explain yourself
and you make me actually enjoy
the other characters that we've seen in
the past saying they're sorry
i never meant to i didn't know that it
you actually surpassed them
with your lack of accountability you
went over the top
trophy booboo that's a trophy right
there
you made them look good wow
how is that possible yo you was wrong
you can't even accept the fact that you
were wrong
you can't even say that you assaulted
him
because you know it don't look good but
that's what you did
and then you go ahead and you say oh you
know what uh it's not me
i'm a sweet person no you're not
twice we've seen that you're not in that
video you're a garbage
human being in that interview you're a
garbage human being
so you're a garbage human being i mean
let's i'm not going to put a referendum
on her person i'm not going to say she's
a garbage person or
abby what if it's not you that's fine
it's your entitlement i just disagree
with it but whatever
why do you disagree with it i just don't
like the idea of just putting a
referendum on on people based off of two
instances
that's it i understand yeah i mean
that's it you can
you can acknowledge that people did
wrong i've just learned not to use the
word garbage when it refers to people
i think people can do terrible things i
think people do garbage things
i just don't like the idea of referring
to people as garbage
whether it's whatever i just don't like
it i agree um
but you know moving past that's what
you're saying think about what effect it
has on the young man
you know to see other people be able to
walk out of the hotel then he starts
coming forward
and the first thing you do is accuse him
and then you tackle him in front of his
file
just violating his sense of safety while
everyone kind of looks onward and it
took a while before police got involved
thankfully they did like weeks later or
whatever but at the time
he felt like this is supposed to happen
and they probably had a conversation
about this so it affects the psyche of
the person involved too and
man when you're accused of something you
don't do it makes you angry
absolutely makes you super angry you're
powerless and you seed
things in other people that later on
bear fruit to bad things if they don't
uh you know cut the cut the roots off
you know it's like wheats
you know you could cut weeds all you
want but if you don't get that deadest
roots
then weeds will grow back so that
dandelion is going to be like what the
[ __ ]
yeah there you go yeah yeah i got a
garden so i had to see those videos like
goddamn these are hard to pull out
right so it's just one of those
unfortunate things that
you know it has longer effects these are
not just instantaneous things
that we enjoy in a video for two minutes
that's why it always makes me
uncomfortable when i watch a video of
like two moms fighting
in front of kids and gets knocked out
like people watch those and i feel
terrible cause i'm like imagine the
psychological impact of a child watching
his mom get beaten up by somebody else
like
it's just terrible and i think people
don't always think about the long-term
ramifications to individuals involved in
these kind of things
whether it's her or him or the father or
the people looking on
you know and i hope i hope she she she
does her time
she assaulted somebody right she put her
hands on somebody
she tackled them without any
justification she needs to go to jail
that's how i feel so you know i better
not see no both him jean's brother show
up or none of that bull
no forgiveness for girls crying on the
stand all right
they're grown adults i don't want you to
view them as women i want you to view
them as men i want you to view them as
adults
and judge them equally under the law
that's all i ask actually you made me
think and i think you're right you're
right
that i was wrong to deemed her as a
garbage human being
i will say that much but this is what i
would say
if i look back at the video and see how
fast you want to move on that's your
privilege
that boy is never going to be able to
move on as fast as you want to move on
never yeah so yeah yeah i mean listen
i probably used that term on people
before in the past and it's very easy to
be super volatile with like yeah it is
i think it was time you know i try to
just cool it down and
i think that's just the main reason why
i disagree on that no i agree and you
know what i was wrong with that
yeah but thank you very much for holding
me accountable i don't know
i was just saying my hey no i know but
still you know what i mean that's how we
have conversation we'll be able to
we're able to grow yeah so that's what
it is but what i did it would have also
been fine if you'd be like i still think
she had garbage yeah i understand what
you're saying but
but if you bring valid it's this if i
say some
you bring some valid points i'm gonna
think about it
i'm gonna be able to think about it's
like oh you know what i may
have and i agree it's a valid point that
you brought
so i could say that yeah oh you know
what i have to watch out for that
because it's easy to deem someone
a garbage human being off of you know
because we've all
you know sinned and did some bad and
some trash we've all did that
so i'ma take that back yeah but
if i had to say one last thing would be
what i said
yeah fair well that's it for today's
video tell us what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear your
thoughts